so today I want to show you one my game
and which actually I played yesterday it
was two Mama's I played unlucky game I
lost first one but I won next two games
and I played for black this game with
international master Eric Rosen who has
written 24 16 so he was of course
strongest player than than I am and I'm
sure that in the future you will play
the strongest players never afraid to
play this ramp because you have always
chance to win the game to make a draw
and of course to lose so in this game
happened d4 Knight f6 Knight f3 d6
Bishop f4 d5 somebody knows the name of
opening Queens pawn game remember about
this okay so if we see five whose idea
to attack the center c3 year to defend
the center Queen b6 what is the main
idea of the small to attack the pawn on
b2 so I decided to play Queen b3 in this
position actually I forgot this opening
because I didn't play this opening alone
of time so I pushed c4 because I was
sure that it's correct mu and I made
this move very quickly and I thought
that my open and will eat my Queen
exchange on b6 and I can push quickly b5
before in the future to solve my problem
this double pawns and that's okay
position for black but then he played in
this position
twin see - I understood that I made a
mistake and who can tell me why why c4
mistake for black because after c4 look
all my pawns are on the lights Class C
for d5 is e 6 f 7 right I have light
squaws Bishop here and this bishop is
bad I cannot develop it in the future
because this bishop has no good spouse
if I will develop to d7 ok but still
these pawns eats eggs defy c4 block it
do you understand this with my c4
remember it's a strategy blunt and bad
move
okay it was interesting for me in this
position to play Queen D saves Bishop
takes d6 Queen takes d6 and to change
this good that squaws bishops be free
for example she takes be free eight eggs
be free Castle kingside
Knight d2 Bishop d7 Bishop d3 knight c6
it's better position for white but it
was interesting for me I didn't play the
small I played knight c6 develop my
knife and he played Knight B D - it was
not good more because in this position
in this opening its a typical idea for
black to play Knight h5 and it was idea
to exchange my knight on the bishop
because bishop on f4 is thrown do you
understand this
and Bishop this Bishop on f4 has not
good [ __ ] so why should play in this
position for example H free
it's a typical idea was idea might H
file and Bishop h2 so now I cannot
exchange the night on the bishop right
and also it was more active moving this
position provide h4
maybe to attack the kin in the future
what why decided to play Knight vide -
so Knight h5 was correct oh I still
decided to develop my pieces Bishop e7
still h3 was good move for white in this
position of his idea to prevent my h5
but why decided to play be free to
attack my pawn on c4 and in the future
to put the pawns in the center so C
takes be free what will you do here Oh
white which move no please why apex be
freest correct move yes we opened the a5
for the rock right and also our pawns go
to the center which is very important in
the middle of the game right ok so again
I should play Knight h5 here was idea to
exchange the bishop and a knight on the
bishop
I played Castle kingside HVD again was
good move for white but why decided to
play Bishop d3 so in this position I
played Bishop d7 Knight e5 what do you
think about this move is a good mobile
bad for white turn the keys
yes first of all night on the file is
instance query file in the center right
and what else
what is the tactical idea here for white
after night if file
what do I want to do tell me okay so if
I to move what white will do so night I
took the bishop on the server and
very well so why the won't take the
bishop on d7 I take this sir and then
take the Polish seven right okay so
that's why I played in this position a
rock FD 8 but it was interesting also
more for me okay c8 what is the main
idea of this move so if Knight takes D
seven nine takes D seven and Bishop h7
same ideas before King h8 right and what
happened in this position
okay if for example bish will go back to
d3 [ __ ] sanity's 9v force dangerous
right and if she takes before of course
rook takes T - so after clean be one who
can take the pawn on C free that's why
it's not good move Bishop d3 and why
should play Queen b1 immediately what
blog will play here
g6 what is the idea of this fall to
throw out the bishop what do I should
play Bishop take g 6f take g6 queen take
g6 and a for example look up six queen
g4 roof g8 Queen H file King g 7h for
Brooke h8 it's unclear position while
has compensation of course for the night
three pawns but it's not so easy to
check Mike in because you have on the
bishop queen and you should spend some
temples to improve your roof for example
rook hpog three so I have time to defend
my kin but it was dangerous and I was
not sure about this position can I
defend my kin or no and I decided just
protect my bishop on d7 so white played
in this position g4 and as for me it was
to Alec and it's a weak form it's a weak
move for the Kings side so it was better
to play Castle kingside
and they've Knight e5 Bishop takes e5
it's better position for white because
white has stone bishop on d3 strong
bishop on Eva if I then in the
she may be a void we'll play Knight a
free to improve the night and attack my
kin on the Kings side but why I decided
to play to attack my kin immediately and
g-form so still a rock a seed was
interested more in this position if my
d7 Knight takes this seven if Queen
Bishop takes h7 King h8 visqueen given E
5 D takes d5 Knight C takes if I Bishop
f5 and rooks take C free physical
position because White King still in the
center so I can defend my kin it's not
so dangerous with my kin is on a shade
its weak of course but white cannot use
it right now and I don't like this pawn
on g4 because one should be of course on
g2 and after Castle white skin will be
ok right
I played in this in this position g6
what do you think about the small
Damocles is it good Milano
it's a little weak for kin right because
my squash g7 h6 severe and white can use
it in the future to play Bishop h6 for
example also maybe white can push h4 h5
to attack the spawn on g6 or maybe to
sacrifice the pieces 9 g 6f take
Joseph's Bishop Teja steps H take gistic
squint egg just like something like this
and that's really dangerous for black in
this position it was interesting to play
for White Knight xd7
Knight XD sound Castle kingside if if I
wish of g3 aruch dc-8 and queen v2 so
why I have two bishops and this for me
it's a little better to play this
position for white two bishops are very
strong right okay so why decided to play
h4 immediately and again as for me it's
to Allah because King still is in the
center and why decided to win the game
immediately but of course it's
impossible because black also made good
mood to develop pieces and why black
should lose the game immediately so I
play the rook a c8 it was interesting
for me in this position to play Knight
takes e5 d takes d5 Knight e4 Bishop
takes D takes Knight takes e4 Bishop c6
Castle kingside Bishop takes Queen takes
and the rook a c8 Here I am without porn
but I have compensation for this pawn
because I attack the pawn on c5 and also
be free I want to play in the future
Luke d2 to use the second rank and
Bishop on f4 is bad because pawn if I
block it so while had have a bad bone
structure and also one on h4 is weak so
that's why it was possible for me to
sacrifice the phone but I have
compensation
here are OKC I played my eggs d7 and
here a black cos choice black and take
Luke takes this seven all night XD 7
which move is better so in this position
it's better to play Knight XD 7 with the
idea of the Queen B - to push ePHI to
open the center because skin is in the
center and the King is in the center the
main idea for you to open the center
right
it's a row strategy idea in the middle
of the game I play the rook takes d7 and
keep it Queen d1 it was interesting for
me to push if I immediately D takes e5
Knight e4 Bishop takes D takes Queen B 1
95 d4 and rook takes D to sacrifice the
ruger like this King takes D to Quincy 6
and still I have compensation because
white skin is weak right white skin is
without castle Keeney 1 and Bishop takes
h4 but I decided to prepare if I move
and I played in this position
first of all Bishop d6 which was the
little slow because he could play Bishop
take this text rook takes d5 Knight h5
and Bishop e2 to attack my night on h5 f
9 g 7c form and it's better position for
white
so he played Bishop g5 what black should
play in this position what is the main
idea of movie shop G file it is to
attack the knight on f6 so what black
should play if he should be stylin let's
the passive because actually I moved
from Easton squad to d6 and the after
Bishop e7 you lost a temple what else
except Bishop is 7 you can defend the
piece what else what is your strategy
area Knight lead also we can move as
that piece right so 98 and it was
interesting for him to play Queen f3 in
this position I D 8 D for D takes d4 b
takes before Bishop before it's equal
possession now because Bishop g5 was not
good more but it was better he decided
to move before immediately and I should
play 98 in this position what is the
main idea of move 98 analyst rogue can
capture the pawn on C free ride okay
good so rook takes c3 it's dangerous
right now after deny did that's why why
should play Knight B 1 then D takes e4
your idea Bishop takes d4 Bishop e7
Bishop takes this time in the rook takes
t7 Castle kingside and Knight b6 still
equal but I played D takes e4 I so very
interesting tactical idea in this
position after Knight takes e4 and who
can tell me what did they play in this
position black move
I decided to sacrifice pieces here how
black can do it now I think is before
years I played this move and if for
example C takes d4
what will you do quinta XD for not good
right now but it's better to play first
of all bishop before he need to then
push the pawn to f5 because if clean d4
here a rock c1 rook takes the one Bishop
takes c1 and actually it's better
position and winning provide so it's
better to open the center like a five
because kin is in the center right G
takes a five he takes the five my g3 and
twin takes d4 if Bishop e3 Queen B -
Keena free King h8 the rooks t1 rooks
the one Queen takes one Queen takes rook
takes rook takes D free Roxy group takes
be free
rook takes e8 King g7 Kinji to f5 and
it's interesting and game but I'm not
sure that black has enough compensation
so it was very fun combination of course
and it's impossible to calculate all the
and everything I didn't see also but I
feel that it should be a interesting for
black and was why I decided to sacrifice
my knight so after and I take before he
decided to play Bishop e3 year and now
what black should play here what is the
main idea of movie should be free
yes why the one take the knight on d4
person so yeah so what black should play
can I move with my knight
alright now I can move but you will eat
my king so it's not good for black of
course so I will show you this move
because it's really not easy to see the
small I took the pawn on c4 him so look
I lost my rook but what black can play
him why I decided to make this small how
black and make up in here
white-skinned still in the center you
know that it's dangerous the main idea
in the opening to make us all quickly so
how black can use it Tammy
Queen before okay it's interesting move
but black has better improve your idea
be it should be for to improve the beer
shop and to open my Roo Conde file which
is very important because this rope will
attack them Bishop on different refugee
and queen on the one so in this
possession it was interesting for white
played Bishop d2 to defend the knight on
c3 Knight xb3
Queen takes be free rook takes D free
Queen c2 and 24 and that sure it's
better position for white black has the
compensation for the rook of course free
upon's and strong attack on the king
also G for pawn is weak H hope on is
weak response faction not good for white
but it was the best line for white why
didn't see the small white played
Keinath one so what is the best move for
black here
I mean
yes of course Bishop takes c3 a proxy
one now what tell me please
we should be - mmm it's not the best
moon because after this should be to my
C file is weak and white can use that
the white can play rook c8 was the idea
to attack my kin and protect my knight
on the 8th so black has better move how
we can defend our bishop on c3 and to
attack white pieces how we can do this
I played Queen c6 in this position so
now white cannot take my bishop on c3
right and also what is the main idea or
this move to attack the rock on each one
very well so why should play rook H free
now what is the best move for black here
how black and sacrifice of the pieces
and have some compensation
and the keys
now I take b3 very well and it clean
takes be free rook takes deeply it was
happening the game but rugby one in this
position was better more for white here
if 95 bishop takes d5 queen takes d5 so
it was better for white to exchange this
bishop from e3 and to have different
squads bishops it's better position so
for black but it's not so big advantage
as after this line rook H freak Knight
takes be free Queen takes be free and
rugby free so white played in this
position Queen c2 what black should play
here
what does the main idea of movement c2
yet attack the rukon deeply so how do I
can defend it
thank you
24 also what is the main idea of the
small quincy for talent if a rogue d2 to
play rock takes c3 so to use the strong
Queen on c4 and that white skin on f1
its weak but suave I decided to play
Queen e2 I played in this position b5
but actually Knight d6 was better
because you should improve your pieces
always and to develop it if Brooke
Geoffrey Knight e4 Luka free and now b5
night only file has been is in the
strong squad and that's why it's good
but I pulled b5 immediately and it was
interesting for white to play Ruby g3
Queen d5 Bishop takes a 7 rook takes up
takes before it's still a void in
position for me but it was better chose
and then white played in the game
white played H file immediately so I
could I could push a 5 and it's been in
position for me because then a 4 a 3 a 2
and they want Queen but I decided to
improve my knight first of all again it
was better for white to play Nigeria
rook Jeffrey here to protect the pawn on
a g4 and after Knight e4 to play rook g1
between d5 it's very in position but I
think it was the best answer for white
white we started to play King g1 in this
position position so what black should
play in this position what is the best
move
thank you
okay how we can do it you have choice
you can take the pawn on G for this the
night or you can take this the Queen
which move is better as usual one who
was good one who was bad so you should
turn before to make your choice so what
is the difference
so after clean tech g4 clean tech g4
night tech g4 we will exchange the
queens and still attack the bishop only
free is that good for black to exchange
the Queen's oh no no why not let's
calculate the pieces who is better white
or black so why have a roof and black
have nine and how many pawns for the
rook yes but I mean that do I have in
this position Knight and four poles for
the rook right nine and four pawns
so what's why it's winning position for
black and endgame is winning and Queen
take g4 it's a strategy good move for
white because if you want on the one for
the main idea for you in the middle of
game to exchange the pieces because
endgame is waiting for you do you
understand this remember about this role
and it's easy to win for me right now
after king of one what will you do is it
good for you to change the pieces why
because black have more material and and
game is winning for black right same
idea rook takes c3 yes rook takes c3
still we exchange your pieces because an
game is waiting for black half takes
every now what
tell me please if Bishop d2 for example
I can play rook c8 check and then kini 2
to defend my phone on e3 so it's not
dangerous which move is better if G
takes stage 5 what what we'll do take
the bishop so it's a blunder
what else is before if you have passed
pawns in the endgame the main idea for
you to push that postpones right and
also after before I protected my bishop
on c3 h6 now what
come please
possible kena faith but I decided to
push a five same idea if you have
postponed the main idea for you to push
the pond so it was the idea a4 a3 a2 a1
Queen they understand this
Keeney too now I decided to play kin a
faith it's possible also to push a four
but I didn't want to help him to develop
the rook for example a rogue d1 king of
a drug dat nice Avenue K 8 a 3 and it's
still when in position for black but as
from Europe on a 8 it's more dangerous
than rookin c1 that's why I decided to
cut the rope on the file after machina
faith so if for example a root d1 in
this position Keeney 7 and now ruh
cannot go to d7 of the eights crown
kindy 3 a 4 still push the pawn here
till C to Kimmie 7 Kings should move to
the center in the endgame it's a rule
King b1f 5 a rock g1 and it was
interesting for me to play G Phi in this
position immediately after of g5 I had
moved III the same idea a3 a2 a1 Queen
and he has not time to stop my phone but
I decide to play enough sex because I
still went in position for me rogue d1 g
5 rook d7 king g6 Luke this is kim
taek's h h6 rook takes is 16 h5 or ok6 a
free of course don't lose this important
form kin a to g4 King b3 g free and if
rook a7 what luck can play here what is
the best move
I think this
h6 possible it's still winning for you
but what our King just saves to defend
the pawn on h7 good but off
yes it's possible what else porn G - and
what if Luke takes stage 7 Thank You
King G 6 and what happened after this
roll can cannot stop the poem yeah you
cannot go to H 1 square because G takes
stage one Queen you cannot go to H 8
square because Bishop takes a shade and
it's winning the position for black
so after the smoke in g6 why the design
so you see it's very beautiful game I
sacrifice it pleases the Lord like tile
tile at what he was the 8th world
champion and he like it to sacrifice of
the pieces and to hell compensation for
it so I wish you to use this tactical
ideas also in your games and to help
compensation and to win so beautiful
games